تتأهب جويا وايدي
البولنديين على قلوبهم. الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان لم نسرع دعم
اوكرانيا فسنفشل جميعا. والمانيا
وكندا واليابان اول الملبين
للنداء الاوروبي. طائرات روسية
تتساقط قرب اوكرانيا فما الذي
يجري? وزيننسكي يعلنها من
ايطاليا. هناك قرارات مهمة
للغاية لحماية اجوائنا. طائرات
الكيان الاسرائيلي تواصل غاراتها
الجوية بكثافة والمقاومة
الفلسطينية ترد بعدة رشقات
صاروخية. وفي مفاجأة غير متوقعة.
الاحتلال يرضخ للهدنة فالى اين
المفر. تهديد تركي شديد اللهجة
والاقتصاد الامريكي يعلن حالة
الطوارئ. والسعودية تقطف من كتاب
الصلح ورقة لتعلن عن في الحوار
السوداني. فهل تنجح الوساطة?
الدعم الغربي في مواجهة الدب
الروسي. الذخيرة تنفد. الجنود
يتساقطون. الاراضي يسيطر عليها
الدب الروسي واوكرانيا في اسوأ
اوضاعها يا سادة. ليقولها مسؤول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيه بوريل. انه ينبغي
تسريع امداد اوكرانيا بالذخيرة
داعيا دول الاتحاد الى تقديم
الامدادات من مخزونها الخاص
وتطويع التحديات اللوجستية
لتحقيق تلك الغاية. فهل من مجيب?
وهنا تشمر الدول الغربية عن
ساعديها وتستجيب لطلب بوريل.
فالحكومة الالمانية اعلنت خطة
مساعدات عسكرية جديدة لاوكرانيا
تعتبر الاكبر من نوعها وتبلغ
قيمتها نحو ثلاثة مليارات دولار.
وتشمل حزمة المساعدات العسكرية
الالمانية دبابات وعربات مدرعة
وانظمة دفاع مضادة للطيران وفق
مجلة ديرش بيجل. فيما اعلنت كندا
وصول ثماني دبابات من طراز
ليوبارد اثنين الى بولندا كانت
وقد وعدت بتسليمهم الى اوكرانيا.
وشددت وزيرة الدفاع الكندية على
ان بلادها ستواصل الوقوف الى
جانب كييف وتزويدها بما تحتاجه
من اسلحة. ان كل هذا هل تدعمون
اوكرانيا مجانا ام ان الفاتورة
ستصل كييف بعد انتهاء الحرب. لكن
مهلا هنا جاءت اليابان مهرولة
لتعلن طوكيو تزويد كييف بمعدات
للطاقة تقدر كلفتها باربعين
مليون دولار وفق وكالة الطاقة
الاوكرانية. اما الدعم البريطاني
الذي وصل كييف فهي صواريخ وقد
بدأ الاوكران باستخدامها فورا
حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسي ان
مقاتلات اوكرانية شنت هجوما
اهداف مدنية في لوجاسك بصواريخ
رغم تصريحات لندن بان هذه
الاسلحة لن تستخدم ضد اهداف
مدنية. بانتظار الرد الروسي. رد
موسكو المبدأي جاء باعلان الدفاع
الروسية تدمير ثماني عشرة مسيرة
اوكرانية ومخازن اسلحة امريكية
وبريطانية الصنع واسقاط مروحية
اوكرانية في خركوف ومقاتلتي ميج
تسعة وعشرين وسوء خمسة وعشرين في
لوجاس وتصفية اكثر من سبعمائة
مسلح. ولا زلنا على ارض المعارك
في اوكرانيا. حيث اعلنت موسكو ان
قواتها حققت تقدما في باخموت
وسيطرت على حي شمال غربي المدينة
الا ان قائد سلاح البر الاوكراني
لوكساندريسكي اكد تقدم القوات
الاوكرانية باتجاه خطوط الاشتباك
مع القوات الروسية قرب باخموت.
واضاف ان القوات الروسية سجلت
خسائر في العديد والعتاد تعبيره،
بينما اعلنت وكالة الانباء
الروسية الرسمية تاس عن تحطم
مروحية عسكرية وطائرة مقاتلة في
منطقة بريانسك الروسية القريبة
من اوكرانيا. وتشير المعلومات
المبدئية الى ان حريقا شب في
محرك الطائرة المروحية قبل
تحطمها فهل هناك يد لكييف في
سقوط هاتين الطائرتين لننتقل من
كييف الى روما، حيث التقى رئيس
اوكرانيا فولو ديمرزليسكي برئيس
وزراء الايطالية جورجيا ميرغني
وبعد مفاوضات بينهما قال
سيلينسكي ناقشنا اليوم تعاوننا
لا سيما في المجالين الامني
والعسكري. هناك قرارات مهمة
للغاية لحماية اجوائنا. مضيفا
انه تمت مناقشة صيغة السلام
الاوكرانية مع رئيسة الوزراء
الايطالية. ومن الطاولة
الايطالية الى السماء البولندية
وعلى طريقة المنطاد الصيني على
وزارة الدفاع الوطني في بولندا
انها سجلت في المجال الجوي
للبلاد ظهور جسم جوي وصل من
بلاروس والذي قد يكون منطاد
استطلاع يقوم بالمراقبة. برأيكم
هل هو منطاد تجسس روسي بعد ان
اشعلت وارسو نار التوتر مع
موسكو. الكيان يرضخ للمقاومة.
عدوى وحمى الحروب تنتقل الى
الاراضي الفلسطينية. الكيان
يستمر بغار على غزة ورد المقاومة
لا يتأخر ليرد الفلسطينيون صاع
صاعين على الاحتلال. حيث اطلقت
المقاومة دفعة جديدة من الصواريخ
من قطاع غزة باتجاه اسرائيل من
بينها صواريخ بعيدة المدى لتعترض
القبة الحديدية بعضا من تلك
الصواريخ. لكن اين ذهبت الصواريخ
الاخرى? هنا سقطت الصواريخ حيث
دوت صافرة الانذار في اسدود
وجديرة ونيتيفوت لتدعو السلطات
الاسرائيلية السكان لدخول
الملاجئ. كما دوت الصافرة ايضا
في عسقلان ومستوطنات غلاف غزة.
من جهته قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
قصفا صاروخيا استهدف جنوب
اسرائيل. وهناك كشف سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي عن خلل في تفعيل
منظومة القبة الحديدية في جولة
القتال الاخيرة مع المقاومة
الفلسطينية. على ذات الصعيد كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن انه
يواصل مواقع للمقاومة في قطاع
غزة وقال انه قصف ثلاث عشرة منصة
صاروخية تحت الارض. واضاف ان
قواته استهدفت ثلاث قاذفات هاون
وموقعا عسكريا للمقاومة في
القطاع. في تلك الاثناء كانت
طائرة حربية اسرائيلية تحلق في
سماء غزة. وبينما كانت المقاومة
قد اعلنت انها ستجدد قصفها
الصاروخي لاسرائيل. مضيفة انها
اعدت نفسها لاشهر من المواجهات
هي الخبر اليقين من وكالة رويترز
التي افادت بموافقة المقاومة
الفلسطينية والكيان الاسرائيلي
على وقف لاطلاق النار بوساطة
مصرية. فالى متى ستستمر هذه
الهدنة? الاحداث والتطورات. قال
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود ان
تركيا لن تنتظر عودة البرنامج
الامريكي لشراء مقاتلة اف خمسة
وثلاثين وستسعى لاستعادة مليار
اربعمائة مليون دولار. افادت
وكالة رويترز نقلا عن مصدر
دبلوماسي سعودي بان طرفي النزاع
في السودان سيستأنفان محادثاتهم
في جدة. واشار المصدر الدبلوماسي
الى ان المحادثات ستركز على وضع
خطة للمساعدات الانسانية في
السودان. بينما افادت هيئة
الطيران المدني السوداني بتمديد
فترة اغلاق المجال الجوي للبلاد
امام حركة الملاحة الجوية حتى
الحادي من مايو الجاري. هدنة
فلسطينية اسرائيلية تدخل حيز
التنفيذ. فهل يرضخ الكيان ويلتزم
بها بعد رشقات الصواريخ
الفلسطينية?